[Music]  there's this kid he didn't think he  could cut it I figured it was just the  usual jitters I take him under my wing  he was wanting to be scared  Pearl Harbor is the greatest  intelligence failure in American history  this can never happen again  I want to make it right  at least some of the boys still want to  fight  the Japanese are playing something  bigger so what's the target  we believe it's Midway Washington  disagrees Washington is wrong if we lose  then Japanese on the west coast Seattle  San Francisco Los Angeles Oh burn  we've got the order to log we need to  throw a punch so they know what it feels  like to be dead  we've got a couple dozen planes it's all  Japanese fleet  this isn't a fair fight  I need these men  you know that you came to  when people are counting money  you'll be able to face anything